hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the Moscow interzoneal
Tournament of 1982. it's a game from
round four and today is a rest today in
the official random World Championship
so I decided to check out a nice classic
and as usual I was just uh you know
minding my own business uh strolling
around Twitter and I saw this very nice
photo posted by Douglas Griffin uh
saying that uh here these two very nice
gentlemen draculous Anderson are
analyzing their game and look at who is
spectating the game you have effing
Galer on the right also in the back of
Gary casparov uh Boris love evekov on
the back right and in the front right
you have none other than a former world
champion Mikhail tal also protector of
this channel I'm sure you guys have
heard of him and I I thought to myself
wow what a what a nice photo uh let's uh
let's just enjoy that photo but then I I
started to think but you know why are
all of these players so uh so immersed
into the game it must be one hell of a
game and so I decided to check out the
game and it is quite the game so uh I I
I I I imagine they were analyzing it
there uh that seems to be it does seem
to be a tournament Hall maybe a Lobby or
something
um uh in in front of the tournament Hall
but who knows there there are some
tables there so this could actually be
the the tournament playing haul but yeah
I was I was very much interested in what
the game was what they were analyzing uh
if tal is interested if casparov is
interested you know that it's definitely
an attacking game and especially since
it's played by dragulio velimir which
was uh like we've said we've covered a
couple of his games on this channel he's
basically known as the the Yugoslav tal
and wolf Anderson I mean he's uh an
incredibly strong Swedish Grandmaster he
was known to be one of the hardest
players ever to defeat he was a master
of end games he was just in you know
absolute Mastermind in Rook end games
and if he did not want to lose you you
not win the game he might not win a lot
of games but you will not beat him if he
decides he he doesn't want to get beaten
so it's definitely an interesting Clash
of style something you would expect uh
you know maybe in their Prime between
Michael talent and the former world
champion tigran Petrosian uh you know
something of the sort uh but yeah let's
check it out it's an incredibly
complicated game and luckily nowadays we
have the luxury of just turning on the
engine but even with powerful engines
like um uh for this game I I use the uh
stockfish 15 version powered by uh the
powered by any new neural network uh at
some depth 40 so the the lines are
nicely analyzed and it's still very very
unclear so I mean they probably spent
like maybe even two hours analyzing this
position all of them and what they found
well we can only we can only uh you know
we can discuss but we we can't really
know maybe it's uh written somewhere
maybe maybe someone one published
something on it I just I just haven't
found any anything of the sort but yeah
let's check it out it's quite a brutal
game I'm sure you guys will enjoy it uh
let's dive straight into it so Moscow
Community 1982 this is run for Dragon
with mirovic versus wolf Anderson Valley
mirovic opens with Ponte E4 as you might
expect from the viewers love tal we have
pawned the C5 going for the Sicilian
Defense Knight F3 Knights the upon to B6
and now Pawn to D4 striking in the
center captures captures and now Knight
to F6 with Ponta uh Knights the C3 and
now you might expect okay maybe another
but not in this game we have Punta E6
this evening variation Bishop to C4 uh
the the Fisher soulzian attack and now
Pawn to A6 and here we have Bishop to B3
this is always a useful move I remember
when I first started the uh learning
about Chess I I had a book by Bobby
Fisher and of course every game where he
played against this line of the ceiling
he played the souls in attack and I
always was very intrigued by this bishop
to B3 move but it's incredibly useful uh
as this bishop can get attacked very
easily if B5 comes uh it's gonna come
with Tempo you're gonna have to move the
bishop then B4 comes with temp you're
gonna have to move the Knight you might
lose the pawn also Queen to C7 might
attack it with Tempo uh so it's best to
just stuck it away to safety right away
and okay Pawn to B5 we have castles and
now Bishop to E7 we have Pawn to F4 and
now Bishop to B7 in terms of uh
correctness or or the strength of the
moves because this is 1982 these are all
uh today's engine moves so the the the
the these guys knew what they were doing
uh don't worry best of the E3 and now
Pawn to B4 challenging the Knight here
we have Pawn to E5 and B captures on C3
we have e captures and F6 uh Bishop
captures and now B characters and C3 so
okay we got some pieces traded uh
castles by Andre the Sun and now Queen
to D2 developing the queen and
connecting the Rooks with Queen to C7
putting more pressure on that Z3 pawn
and the now comes Rook 8 D1 and let's
Rotator D1 deserves a lot of attention
like I said the the analysis for this
game might take a bit longer but the
limes the lines are just Exquisite so
the idea is what happens if Pawn to F5
here and of course an attacker like
Valley mirovic definitely thought about
this uh but it's uh so complicated
I mean so many things can happen look at
this point the E5 and now look at this
bishop to G5 you know what is happening
in this position uh point is that if you
capture on D4 then a white can capture
on F6 and if G character is now Queen to
H6 already with the threat of Rook F4
Rook the G4 checkmate with Queen to G7
so uh black will be able to save himself
from Checkmate and it will be some uh
some draw after Rook to E8 to Rook to F4
now 30 Rook to G4 Rook D4 now Saves the
Day for example captures captures and
queen captures on F6 and it's a it's a
wild position but uh you you will hold
it so nothing to worry about the queen
covers the F7 Square
uh so it's fine the idea is that after
Pawn to F5 and E5 and Bishop to G5 you
don't go for E Capture Sandy for black
has this very nice Knight to D7 and now
uh already uh it's a very hard to to
find good lines look at this Knight the
E6 attacks the queen and here you really
should capture that Knight F captures F
capture is not threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries Queen to B6 check
Bishop to E3 blocking check attacking
the queen and not Knight the C5 you move
the Knight block uh The Bishop's attack
towards the queen now E7 with check you
cannot capture on B3 the the Knight is
pinned like we said Rook to F7 and now
look at this uh Rook captures an F6
beautiful stuff G captures and now Queen
to F2 uh putting pressure on that F6
Pawn because the Rook is pinned and also
now you're putting pressure on the
Knight and you don't have to worry about
uh yeah as long as the queen was on D2
the Knight isn't really pinned and I can
capture on B3 and then the White Queen
gets attacked as well so after Queen F2
let's say queen queen C7 Queen the G3
check King h8 now you have to capture
there's really nothing better Bishop
captures and now Queen captures on E7
you're gonna go back some like Bishop to
C4 but not black pushes D5 and black
survives the attack black is perfectly
fine here uh he he most likely even
better it's better the F1 Knights the E4
attacks the queen puts pressure here uh
it's uh well a very very comfortable
position for black so that's why not F5
right away velimirovic prepares it with
a rook 8 D1 as all great attackers do
and now uh the position is a bit
different and you should meet this with
Pawn to D5 for the point being that if
D5 F5 now E5 is much much different but
in the game Anderson played Knight to D7
and now the valley mirror which goes for
it pawn to F5 and it is now as of move
16 that this position has never been
reached again so let's see how Anderson
defense as he is a very very strong
Defender we have Pawn to E5 and not
Knight the E6 again attacking the queen
and the Rook so F captures with Pawn
captures on E6 now again attacking the
Knight threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and now Knight the C5 uh
here in this line D5 is better
uh point being that after D5 you give up
the Knight here e captures and D7 Queen
captures and now white really doesn't
have all that much he either leaves the
black with this incredible Center or or
he has to trade Bishop captures Queen
captures and then everything just gets
traded off the board captures captures
and captures and oh let's say Rook after
C8 white is up a pawn but it's a double
C Pawn you already have a rook on the C
file the bishop controlling this
diagonal uh White will not be enjoying
any extra pawns on the C file so this is
uh well objectively best but in the game
night the C5 was played and now he gives
the velimirovich a little bit of a
chance here Ponte E7 with check and okay
The Rook is attacked so you have to move
it Rook to F7 and he goes for the line
Rook captures an F6 but now we don't
have G captures on F6 instead we have
Knight captures and B3 uh as the queen
is still on D2 so it makes sense to
throw in this Knight captures on B3 move
you eliminate bishop and you don't
really care because if G captures then
there's Queen captures on D6 and look at
this now the queen is hanging and The
Rook here is also attack so you're gonna
have to capture here Rook captures on D6
and now uh if if Knight captures on B3
it doesn't really matter uh just Rook
the d8 to check and there's no saving
this position now if you trade the Y
just gets a queen enter game if you do
nothing again E8 is Queen so you're not
going to be able to capture on B3 you're
gonna have to go King to G7 or something
but then just Bishop captures an F7 King
captures Bishop captures and C5 and the
D7 Pawn is protected because of all the
nasty discoveries here so you will just
resign here so okay after Rook captures
on F6 Knight captures on B3 first this
is very important this is the only move
that does not lose by force uh
presumably uh Rook captures on F7 look
at this sacrificing the queen but it's
not easy to accept this if you if you
capture the queen then E8 Queen brings
another queen into the game and after
this one is captured as well then Rook
captures on C7 and now your knight is
hanging and also your Bishop on B7 is
saying so we're gonna lose a piece and
of course um you're gonna be uh you're
not gonna be down a piece you're gonna
be down an entire Rook uh so okay after
Rook captures on F7 King captures on F7
by Anderson again he's playing the all
the best defensive moves uh and this is
the the position where you really have
to figure out how to approach it do you
do you go for something you have to move
the queen your queen is hanging you play
Queen D3 do you capture the Knight or do
you play Queen to F2 with check and try
and mount some sort of an attack so uh
there are there's Merit to all of all of
these moves but we're gonna discuss only
a few of them so C captures on B3 it
makes sense if you can capture the
Knight why not capture it then comes
King capture Sun E7 and now after Queen
D3 going after the H7 Pawn there's Queen
C6 and black has a lot of Contra play
here already threatening Checkmate Rook
the D2 and now Rook the f8 to getting
that inactive Rook into the game and you
don't really care about any
uh pawns hanging on H7 if Queen captures
an H7 doesn't really matter just Queen
T4 and decentralizes the black queen
very nicely puts pressure on the bishop
and this is never even an option if you
capture here then you're just not uh
defending enough stuff so Queen captures
on G7 let's say King's gonna go to E8
and now white is without a move there
are too many threads so the queen has to
keep an eye on Checkmate the bishop here
is hanging and uh where do you move the
bishop that's the that's the real
question you move the bishop to F2 then
comes Queen to B1 with check and you're
out of squares you have to block with
something and you will just get
checkmated once the black queen gobbles
up everything so you can go for that
after Rook to f8 you're gonna have to
play C4 and then okay the game continues
we're gonna play Rook to F7 now uh at
the defense across the seven Frank let's
zip onto H4 Pawn to H6 now Queen to G6
and you get something like this where
it's maybe uh maybe white can't push for
more than a drop but it's a very very
unclear you would have to really find
unique Solutions here so okay after King
captures an F7 uh C characters on B3 was
not played Queen to F2 by with check by
available and now comes King captures on
E7 now it seems like you don't have to
go to G8 so uh King captures on E7
grabbing that pawn and now this is the
moment where the magic happens it's very
hard to figure out what to play here uh
I can ask you guys to pause the video
here and try to figure out the the only
winning move uh and that's exactly what
I'm gonna do so feel free to pause the
video uh and find the winning idea for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on having a true
chess intuition because here the winning
line is some uh 20 moves and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Queen to H4 with check not
capturing the the Knight right away uh
the the thing is you have to play Queen
to age for check and after the king
moves uh now you capture the Knight but
now it's now it's different as you'll
see what happened in the game because
now after Queen C6 threatening Checkmate
You're Gonna Play Queen G4 and after
Queen D7 offering your queen trade Queen
to H5 check and after G6 Queen the H4
still keeping an eye on this diagonal
and after Queen to C6 again threatening
Checkmate now you're gonna play Queen to
F2 once you've created some weaknesses
here and after Queen to E4 a wonderful
centralizing move by black Bishop to G5
now you control this diagonal as well
and now uh black although black still
controls this diagonal there's really no
good way
um uh the threatening anything for
example if Rook the C8 you're going to
play C4 and now if King to D7 because
there really aren't any uh more active
moves from black you have to try and
hide your king to the queen side now you
start the attack Queen F7 check King the
C6 and now Bishop to E7 beautiful stuff
here just going after the uh D6 pawn and
there is no defending it now you don't
have to worry about Checkmate the king
is in between the bishop Queen battery
and now uh best for black is just to go
for a queen trade Queen E3 checking F1
Queen F4 check captors captures and now
Rook captures and D6 with check King to
C7 and now Rook the F6 and this is how
you how you win you're up a pawn and
you're gonna win at least one more Pawn
because let's say King these seven
attacks the bishop Bishop to B4 uh now
this Pawn is uh this Pawn is hanging and
there's no way to uh definitive play
something like G5 just Rook F7 check
goes after for this pawn and then of
course you are completely winning King
C6 Rook captures on H7 and now you are
up two pawns but this is uh of course uh
not uh easy to find that's a lot of
moves uh I left the uh the stockfish
plus
um uh plus um and the neural network to
some depth 40 to Crunch the numbers uh
you know uh took Meadow for a walk and
then when I came back I I saw this line
and I was very happy when I saw it so
that's why I was very interested um at
the the to maybe try and find out how
how much of it uh where the former world
champions uh able to find on the board I
mean you have great attackers like uh
like filimirovich talcas part of I mean
uh probably they saw a lot of lines but
in the game eval mirovic did not go for
this check first he played C capture
some B3 first and this is one very very
important Tempo now comes Rook de fate
and now it's different we have Queen's
age for check King the E8 but now the
Rook is already an f8 so there's an
extra Defender here Queen captures on H7
was played now comes Queen captures and
C3 and now Queen to H5 with check we
have Rook to F7 and now Queen to h8 to
check and he was in this position on
move 27 that Dragon villimirovic and
Wolf Anderson agreed to a draw as there
is nothing more to be done here and
there really isn't you cannot push for
more with white
uh uh after Rook the f8 attacks the
queen queen H5 check uh rooked F7
there's no way to add any pressure you
don't have time for Rook F1 the bishop
on E3 is hanging you first have to tense
to your Bishop uh and well there's just
no no not really uh no good Square for
it it's like I'm like Bishop to C1 then
already Queen to C2 is winning for black
look at this attacking The Rook now uh
but not only that threatening Checkmate
the queen is defending the Rook but the
queen will be overwhelmed how do you
defeat the defended Checkmate now there
is no good move you have to play a silly
move like Bishop to D2 then comes a
brilliancy bishop to F3 look at this
attacking the queen and the Rook uh and
now if G character is an F3 then of
course Queen captures and D1 as the
queen no longer guards The Rook so y
just falls apart and if you don't uh
capture this there really isn't a move
that you can play uh so uh if uh if
velimirovic would have pursued more than
a draw here under some would definitely
find this and he would crush him so I'm
good for him to to force a draw here
with a with a nice repetition with Queen
DJ check but yeah you've seen how much
uh stuff there was uh how much was
played how much wasn't played and that's
why uh you know when when I saw this
photo I was like wow that that must be
one hell of a game if you know uh a
great attackers like these guys uh
gathered around trying to trying to uh
unwind everything that's happening and
you know solve the positions I mean
absolutely crazy stuff uh but yeah the
tournament if you guys are interested in
the standings I also have the standings
of the tournament casparov uh won the
tournament very nicely uh with 10 out of
13 and that's seven seven wins zero
losses and six draws second place eight
and half points Alexander believski
third place uh shared with Mikhail tal
and wolf Anderson then effing Geller
with seven and a half uh also Garcia
Gonzalez and so on and so on you can see
the mirror which over there with five
and a half uh as he is you know quite uh
quite an aggressive player so sometimes
it didn't go uh all his way and made his
dreaming of uh of crazy positions again
probably he is uh analyzing this
position as we speak but yeah
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh you can check out the
photo one more time if you want I mean
absolutely stunning photo so uh you know
uh do you use Twitter if you can you can
follow some nice accounts like Douglas
Griffin and you can uh enjoy more photos
like this if you guys are into that uh
so yeah that's the game and a little bit
of everything so hope you guys enjoyed
that um a bit of a change of pace from
the from the chess 960 but you know I
thought we we deserve it after three
days of of random positions so even this
you know positions in these game in this
game were even more random but uh you
know what I mean uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh I would
like to thank Jeff Morrow yeah for
Nathan hey asleep uh Jack obied and more
chess960 for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day